[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was one thing that really struck me
was the speed of which the streets
became vacant Times Square Abbey Road
you know these are areas that are always
teeming with people you know the temple
bar area and in Dublin there's always
folks there day night always it's
significant and and I've never seen
anything like it you know having this
global network of cameras and you know
especially after 9/11 everywhere in New
York was really quiet and it was similar
but it wasn't to this extent and
certainly globally it wasn't anything
like what we're experiencing now our you
know purposes better lies to visual
information so what better than giving
this visual information to people to
help them at a time like this
explore the planet feel comfort in the
fact that the world still out there
we're all gonna get back out there you
can still go there you can still go sit
on a beach virtually and experience
things that you will hopefully be able
to experience very soon again in the in
real life
[Music]
this camera is allowing us to appreciate
the beauty of the CP but of course a
sinking without citizen it is not really
as deeply it's like that it just a
postcard something unbelievable
something amazing but something also I'm
a real girl
because City Thunder have the soul of
the city and we are in town so hotel
cannot exist without tourists especially
Venice because 90% of the turista are
also international tourists there is a
lot a lot of uncertainty in town about
how we are supposed to reopen because I
think is quite difficult to to welcome
guests with masks with the temperature
control and when witnesses know
[Music]
so since lockdown came into force on the
23rd of March we've had about 20 times
as many visitors to our webcams page
that we would expect at this time of the
year well we already know that people
feel happier and healthier when they're
connected with nature but at a time like
this one we're more isolated from the
people that were closest to spending
that time connecting with wildlife
through the screen can actually help to
to make you feel a lot better in
yourself and they're like the most
addictive soap operas really you get to
know the characters you get to know the
individual badges the barn owls the
puffins and you just want to keep going
back and getting to know them even
better so it can can really help to
soothe our souls at the moment I think
the extraordinary thing that this
pandemic has shown is what nice though
again we're all in it together this is a
global crisis as indeed is the climate
an ecological crisis nearly everyone
they we've changed our lives you know
you have people who are frontline
workers and your family or people who
are obviously suffering but also there
are changes to the lives which maybe for
the better so for example you might
actually spend more time with your
family you might spend a little less
time commuting and indeed you might
connect more to nature on your doorstep
now all of that are qualities and
emotions and experiences which I think
somehow we'll need to capture when we do
emerge
[Music]
I kind of in a kinder to something
morning I've been working shifts or 15
years and Sunday mornings always that
kind of easy easy time you could just
take take stock and then catch hold it
without that lot of things there's not
much else going on and that's what we're
seeing most days right because there's
less traffic as well speeds have gone up
that's like because normally it's in
London you may be getting 5 10 miles an
hour after that key actions we're
getting a more more serious from jagged
wise we've got a balcony up on seven
floor here you got there for a cup of
coffee
and you can hear tweeting you can hear
the rumble of the train but that's it
and it's very peculiar this is London
Susan should be like this he should be
hustle-bustle horns sirens everything
going off the trains probably past but
on Irving anyway
[Music]
and especially during this crisis a lot
of people from their home are curious
what's going on in the next city or in
the opposite side of the world people
use it as a virtual window and
construction site saves the person of
the office travel time and that will not
change after the crisis is over because
they got accustomed to the fact that
they can watch remotely and so no longer
need to be in traffic for one or two
hours and we have seen an increase of
requests for once this crisis is over
the regulations will change and of
course theater cinema needs to take
precautions one of the precautions now
is installed thermal cameras the thermal
camera is because our body has a
temperature 37 degrees is 36 and half
you will see at the difference between a
sick person and a not sick person now we
get hundreds of people watching you know
because I'd like to watch the streets
and their people walking by and I guess
they look like you know like people
watching but from their home and
unfortunately obviously the the bars and
stuff of clothes and try them out so but
you know we don't really get that many
views through analysis that's nothing
for people to watch but the one the one
that's getting the most attention now is
it's called Samui Yacht Club and it's
the it's like a view of the sea some
people right so you know they find it
very relaxing they put it on in the
background and they just like to hear
the city noise and stir
you
[Music]